wreckage is being recovered far and wide
as russian aviation officials try to
piece together what happened
some debris from the crash was found on
a mountainside in the far eastern region
of kamchatka
more pieces were fished out of the sea
other parts of the plane were found
about five kilometers from the airport's
runway
in the town of palana today a plane
following the route from petro pavlov's
kamchatsky to polana crashed
the tragedy is said to have occurred
during the landing presumably the plane
was making a second approach and
visibility was poor
air traffic control lost contact as the
plane neared its destination
heavy fog may have caused the plane to
go off course a criminal investigation
is underway
but the plane's owner says everything
was technically sound before takeoff
local officials have partially backed
this up confirming no problems were
detected with the russian-made antonov
aircraft before it departed
the aircraft was made in 1982 it has a
valid certificate of airworthiness
the crew passed a pre-flight inspection
currently
search and rescue activities are
underway all
28 people on board are believed dead but
so far
no bodies have been recovered a local
leader and two children were among the
passengers
the rugged terrain around polana is
making the search a slow and arduous
process
the area where the wreckage was found is
difficult to access
especially as night falls vinton monahan
al jazeera